doute alors voici comment emmanuel
macron à justifier cette politique
c'était mardi soir en marge de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
qui existent aussi dans notre pays on
doit les voir ensemble si je me mets à
dire la france devient le port d'accueil
de tous les bateaux qui part d'afrique
d'abord ça n'est pas une solution à
laquelle je crois et ensuite ça n'est
pas soutenable même politiquement en
france pour nos propres équilibre parce
que toutes celles et ceux qui
légitimement sont inquiets aussi par la
force des migrations est ce que l'europe
connaît depuis plusieurs années diront
on a là un président qui ne nous protège
pas comme il le devrait et ils auraient
raison il vint sur ce point vous donner
le point à emmanuel macron oui oui bien
sûr mais ce n'est pas tellement lui qui
parle ce sont les populistes qu'il a
derrière et qu'il intime en fait de
changer de politique parce que le
maquereau nisme lui s'ouvrir est bien
volontiers d'ailleurs il l'a théorisé
ils s'ouvriraient bien volontiers ans au
nom des droits de l'homme de la non
discrimination tout ce que vous voulez à
ces migrants là et c'est vrai que dans
le fond sémillant la scène représente
une cinquantaine de personnes ce qui est
absolument rien donc on est dans le
symbole et il est également c'est
laisser la pression symbolique de ce
vote populaire qui ne veut plus entendre
parler de cette immigration qui fait en
plus qui est qui qui s'introduit dans le
en europe à travers une sorte de
chantage aux bons sentiments auquel se
prêtent l'aquarius enfin et certaines
des organisations humanitaires qui qui
qui joue un jeu très ambigu entre les
passeurs et eux-mêmes en facilitant leur
travail donc tout ceci maintenant est
devenu assez irritant et moi je me
félicite en effet d'entendre ce
gouvernement qui était quand même assez
réceptif aux arguments qui tendait à
vouloir accueillir tout le monde se
raidir est en tout cas se raidir sous la
pression de l'opinion mais ce serait
dire quand même le site schmitt vous
leur répondez à yvan et plus
généralement est ce que
emmanuel macron a raison de dire qu'un
accueil massif ça fait monter le
populisme et que c'est plus possible
je crois que si compliqué avec un manuel
macron c'est que comme l'ensemble des
chefs d'état en europe que ce qu'il soit
populistes ou se disent progressistes
ils sont en réaction par rapport à une
situation qui ne mettraient absolument
pas et pour l'instant ils sont face à
des bateaux où il ya beaucoup moins par
exemple on est au niveau de migrants de
2012 donc on n'est plus dans la crise
migratoire dans son caractère aigu à
laquelle par exemple angela merkel avait
réagi en accueillant des centaines
voilà des centaines de milliers de
migrants est ce le fait qu'elle se
trouve aujourd'hui en situation
difficile est sans doute lié au fait
qu'elle a accueilli beaucoup de migrants
donc moi je suis pas en train de nier la
réalité
simplement ce que je constate c'est que
en politique lorsqu'on se dit
progressiste
on doit aller à l'offensive et je ne
trouve pas que emmanuel macron soit
alors foncez sur ce sujet je pense que
chaque arrivée de bateau se traduit par
des négociations
ridicule parce que c'est 50 personnes 60
personnes en ce moment où 100 personnes
et à chaque fois folle et répartis entre
trois à quatre pays et à chaque fois on
a droit à un très grand discours
ampoulés nous disons que c'est
merveilleux et qu' il ya eu un partage
des responsabilités entre pays européens
est de plus en plus quelle que soit la
famille politique à laquelle on
appartient on voit que c'est une langue
de bois
donc la question c'est comment est ce qu
on entre de nouveau dans la réalité par
rapport à ce qui se passe en
méditerranée et donc il faut évidemment
aller voir du côté des pays d'où
viennent les migrants moi je regardais
par exemple si tu sais pas si au maroc
puisque vous savez que c'est les
garde-côtes marocains qui ont tué une
marocaine de 22 ans
eh bien il ya eu un espèce d'immense
débat qui a commencé à apparaître au
maroc parce que ces démarches 4 contre
une marocaine donc il ya quelque chose
qui est en train de se passer en afrique
du côté de ces pays d'où viennent les
migrants sur l'idée de comment est ce
qu'on fait pour arrêter une situation où
au fond ce sont des gens de chez nous
qui meurent l'europe visiblement ne
pourra pas les accueillir
donc moi je trouve qu'il faut reprendre
l'offensive et je trouve que le discours
d' emmanuel macron sur la protection
je le trouve assez faible je pense qu'il
est temps qu'ils disent l'europe ça ne
fonctionne pas voilà ce que je propose
est c est pas seulement
dublin 2 qui est un truc
incompréhensible pour les sociétés il
n'a pas la solution tout simplement si
la solution toute chose il est créatif
je crois que ceux dits créatif alors
mauvais solution situations d'urgence
qu'il faut bien gérer dans l'urgence
fergane où il faut comme le dit
il faut reprendre le problème à la base
et ne pas laisser comme ça gouvernée par
les sondages
je pense que oui mais accueillir les
bateaux pas moi je suis pour une manière
claire la libre circulation des
personnes
et effectivement je mets ça va jusqu'où
pas ce que ça veut dire ça comme ça
c'est évident ce que je veux dire c'est
que aujourd'hui mais ce qui me frappe
avec le continent européen c'est qu'on
est passé à 58 personnes sur un compte
de 500 millions d'habitants et on
panique sur notre incapacité
effectivement à gérer ces flux de
personnes
moi je reprend l'histoire des migrations
en occident et notamment dans un grand
pays comme les etats-unis où on a connu
des vagues migratoires qui était
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus puissante
que celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui est
ce qu'on interroge à metz et quelles
sont les conditions institutionnelles
qui font qu'on arrive à absorber plus
facilement des flux de migrants à telle
ou telle époque aux états unis on a
connu des vagues de migration au 19e et
20e siècles de population de 2,2 plein
de régions ou de plein de cultures
différentes c'est un pays qui a réussi à
assimiler ça peut plus les autres s'ils
avaient des institutions beaucoup plus
flexible beaucoup plus ouverte
un marché du travail une économie
beaucoup plus ouverte qui permettaient
aux individus qui arrivait sur le
continent américain de s'insérer dans la
société beaucoup plus facilement en
europe on est empêtré dans des
institutions rigide des états providence
qui exclut qui rendent l'accès au marché
du travail compliqué du coup tout si
rigidité font qu effectivement quand il
ya 100 personnes qui arrivent on ne sait
plus comment les intégrer on ne sait
plus comment les inclure moi je pense
pas question elle est beaucoup par
exemple tensionnelle
on n'a pas du tout la même histoire que
celle des états unis c'est la
comparaison ne vaut pas parce que les
etats unis se sont construits sur une
immigration l'europe c'est une vieille
europe qui naturellement c'est s'est
construit sur une immigration
intra-européennes bien sûr il ya eu des
passages entre les italiens et les
français etc
on a eu droit à une eau rennes qui ont
été allemand italien et ses jeunes à
poser de problème à personne mais
aujourd'hui c'est son seul c'est une
civilisation c'est une immigration de
civilisation qui qui qui pose problème
et d'ailleurs et vous voyez bien que
quand valence par exemple en espagne de
port de valence accueilli les bras
ouverts le l'aquarius justement c'était
l'aquarius il ya deux ou trois mois
immédiatement il ya eu un flux de
clandestins qui sont passés par dessus
les barrières de ceux de salta de salt
adam territoire marocain avec 2,13 et
d'une manière très agressive avec des
prisons des agressions contre les gardes
les militaires qui les militaires
espagnols l'espagne avec des vraies
scènes alors et dvd vraie scène
d'invasion cette fois ci et vous
remarquerez que maintenant on n'entend
plus parler des appels de valence à
vouloir accueillir à nouveau l'aquarius
et lors qu'il n'avait pris que deux
cents personnes de mémoire donc ce sont
d'accord mais on est on est quand vous
dites 50 personnes je suis bien d'accord
avec vous c'est absolument dérisoire
mais c'est encore une fois ce sont des
symboles qui sont lancés précisément à
ceux qui sont qui sont candidats au
départ et qui voit au nos faiblesses ou
non nos riches où nous rigidité donc il
faut mieux faire preuve de faux bien
envoyer comme message un message de
rigidité de firmes étaient plutôt qu'un
message de faiblesse
c'est ce que c'est l'analyste a dû faire
macro pas une grande spécialiste mais en
tout cas ce qui me fera dans
l'émigration je pense qu'elles vont
durer la l'écart démographique entre
l'afrique et l'europe il ya quand même
un sujet là important et je suis assez
d'accord ce qui est ce qu'il dit c'est
comme le niveau de vie s'accroît en
afrique subsaharienne ça va plutôt
tendance à la réparation des gens pour
avoir le moyen de partir ça c'est assez
évident après je pense que là où c'est
très difficile pour l'europe et moi j'ai
pas la solution c'est qu'on arrive celle
se produise amont il ya une crise aussi
de la civilisation européenne des choses
ont changé ce que tu es l'europe en 1950
avec une société qui était plus
patriarcale c'est un fait
où les familles ont divorcé pas où le
catholicisme
travail protestant steam était présent
prégnant et au jour pratiquer une
religion aujourd'hui n aurait mandaté
ses des changements majeurs de société
et dans une société qui est en plein
bouleversement qui voilà qui en pleine
crise d'identité de au sens vraiment
profond et même sans immigrés elle
aurait été en crise d'identité là dessus
harry par dessus une population qui ne
viennent une civilisation différentes
forcément ça crée beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés mais si on avait si on était
une société j'imagine au travers avec et
avec une indigne identité beaucoup plus
forte beaucoup plus affirmée beaucoup
plus stable avec moins de crise voilà
deux ans de prison suivant ce vraiment
proche du diable de changement ce serait
très différent serait une immigration si
nous n'étions pas nous mêmes faits par
patty hewes team nous ne doutions pas
nous mêmes de ce que nous sommes c'est
un peu actuelle c'est que de toute façon
nous n'empêchons pas la migration c'est
à dire que la vérité c'est qu'elle se
produit que macron parle ou pas à l'onu
elle elle se produit elle est due à des
facteurs de plus en plus multiple par
exemple les migrations climatiques qui
est énorme et on n'est pas on ne sait
pas ce qui va se passer c'est ça la
vérité c'est qu'en ayant peur la
migration nous avons peur de l'avenir et
en même temps nous ne pouvons rien faire
contre le fait que les migrants vont
continuer que la migration va plutôt se
développer
non je n'ai défier l'australie australie
à 10 ans de passeport il ya les
migrations ne passe plus mais je crois
pas que nous soyons dans la situation de
l'australie géographiquement chéri vent
qui est qui est totalement isolé dans
l'océan pacifique
mais nous sommes nous avons nous voulons
des réponses et nous allons des
frontières terrestres nous avons laissé
la grèce et l'italie dans une situation
dramatique nous avons essayé de négocier
avec la turquie pour nous débarrasser de
notre responsabilité sur les migrations
et donc en fait on est dans une
situation plus grave qui a trois quatre
ans alors qu'à ce moment là on aurait pu
traiter les choses d'une manière plus
unis la deuxième chose que je voulais
dire c'est que il faut traiter aussi les
choses par rapport au territoire
moi j'ai travaillé sur les questions
migratoires et j'ai vu comment dans des
petits villages des petites villes on
avait peur de l'arrivée des migrants
parce qu'ils étaient différence à
rejoindre ce qu'on se disait sur la
question des discriminations
il faut aussi que l'état français les
agents français soient capables d'aller
parler aux personnes et pas seulement de
faire des grands discours
et d'expliquer qu' on va mettre dix
personnes va personnes 30 personnes si
on veut accueillir des migrants et même
50 personnes ça voudra dire s'adresser
aux enseignants s'adresser au maire
pour le vent accueillent les migrants
vous voyez ce qui se passe en banlieue
quand même de regarder ouvrez les yeux
voyez ce que sont devenus les banlieues
dans les ghettos voyez 60 blessés contre
société vous envoyer chez vous appelez
migrants des gens qui ont à la demande
et émigré oui bien sûr qu'ils ont
souvent la nationalité française
on donne encore quelques réactions
pourra pas prolonger le débat anti mac
ivan a raison nacre ont agi parce qu'il
a peur de l'opinion au delà des mers
c'est le pseudo de notre internaute
l'aquarius n'est que la toute petite
pointe de l'iceberg des mafias qui
organise ces immigrations d'un sujet
dont on a déjà pas mal parler ici d'un
point de vue et leurs maquereaux et
coincé s'il continue il ya la
possibilité que marion maréchal passe
aux prochaines présidentielles c'est un
pronostic
j'aurais juste qu'on s'arrête sur notre
sondage vous l'avais dit en titre
sondage à paraître demain dans le figaro
sondages aux hawks à denso consulting
alors vous êtes de trois quarts a
approuvé le refus des manuels ma
commande d'accueillir l'aquarius et vous
êtes également près de 60% a estimé que
la solution européenne est la bonne mais
elle est majoritairement rejetée par les
sympathisants les républicains et un
rassemblement national cette solution
européenne
on fera pas le tour du sujet aujourd'hui
mais en tout cas merci d'avoir contribué
à faire avancer le débat
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre et vous
avez rendez vous demain avec guillaume
roquette pour un nouveau point de vue
[Musique]